la pression montait et montait
l'opposition au sait le temps chaque
jour un peu plus pour réclamer
l'expulsion du diplomate chinois qui
aurait ciblé un élu canadien dans une
campagne d'intimidation est-ce que le
premier à le courage d'excuser cet agent
maintenant on lisez dans l'enjeu de
l'ingérence chinoise le gouvernement
Trudeau cède finalement dans un geste
rare
Ottawa expulse le Diplomat chinois jaway
qui aurait ciblé les proches du député
conservateur Michael Chang la ministre
des Affaires étrangères écrit j'ai été
très clair nous ne tolérerons aucune
forme d'ingérence étrangère dans nos
affaires internes les diplomates au
Canada ont été avertis que s'ils
adoptent ce type de comportement ils
seront renvoyés chez eux le Diplomat
chinois doit quitter le pays d'ici 5
jours l'ambassade chinoise réplique avec
des menaces la Chine prendra des mesures
de représailles et le Canada devra en
subir toutes les conséquences
cette expulsion aurait dû avoir lieu il
y a deux ans estiment le député Michael
Chang ça crée un reste moi et ma famille
parce qu'il y a quelqu'un ici au Canada
pendant la dernière deux ans qui est
faite une cible
à moi et ma famille à ses yeux cette
affaire doit servir d'exemple au reste
du monde nous ne nous laisserons pas
intimider d'illus conservateur
l'opposition a obtenu ce qu'elle voulait
mais continue de talonner le
gouvernement
tous les partis d'opposition ont appuyé
une motion conservatrice appelant à la
création d'un registre des agents
d'influence étrangers et a déclenché une
enquête publique sur la gérance
étrangère dans les élections un enquête
publique au plus sa crainte pour qu'on
puisse aller au fond des choses avant de
confirmer l'expulsion du diplomate le
gouvernement a pris le temps de
consulter des pays alliés une preuve
kotawa prend les risques de représailles
au sérieux la langue des tensions des
deux Michael est encore fraîche en
mémoire ici Louis Blouin Radio-Canada
Ottawa